hey what's up my name's samuel leeds and
i'm a property entrepreneur and not only
do i make a lot of money in property but
i also put out youtube videos and have a
training company and teach people in
property as well so if you watch winners
wednesday you'll see a lot of my success
students start off making their money in
a strategy called rent to rent and
the thing is with rental rent is you can
make quite a lot of money doing it but
like any business and be under no
illusion rent to rent is a property
business and
a business is when you have a product
and a product and you have a customer
and with rent to rent your product is
your house and your service to the
landlords that's your product and
service and then your customer is your
tenants effectively rent around is when
you rent a property off a landlord and
usually it will be a reasonably low rent
it will be off a particular type of
landlord and a particular type of
property this doesn't work with every
house and with every landlord so let me
pre-qualify firstly the landlord the
landlord it has to be a landlord who is
happy to receive a
low
guaranteed rent so he can't be a
landlord that wants as much as he can
possibly get every single month and he's
looking to really no it needs to be
someone who's more hands-off that just
wants a quiet life no hassle and he
wants a guaranteed rent that needs to be
the qualification of the landlord i
might just text these living or live out
landlords and say
would you be open to a guaranteed rent
or potentially selling your house i'll
send that to all the landlords and all
the agents i'll phone them and get a
feel for what the area is like and what
the rents are like and stuff like that
and then together i should be getting my
market research while also putting out
my marketing messages so here's the
message i'm going to write i'm going to
say so hey i've just seen your property
on spare room would you be interested in
receiving a fixed guaranteed rent or
maybe selling your property all together
if so please text back and let's jump on
a quick call samuel boom so that is
my message hi peter my name's samuel i
think
we just missed each other a couple of
times
but great to speak i was just calling
about your uh your apartment that you've
got on i saw it on gumtree
um so it looks good i think you said
that the um
i was looking at the pictures i think
does it does it come furnished
okay fantastic and it's on for 950
pounds per calendar month is that right
yeah all right awesome fantastic so
i'd love to have a look around your uh
your apartment it looks really nice and
i love the fact that it's furnished and
the location is uh absolutely fantastic
are you are you the landlord do you do
you own the apartment
nice
nice that's not a bad investment for you
have you got more than one in the block
or is it just that one you've got
i know
okay nice fantastic so um so basically
yeah so i've got a company so it would
be a corporate let i don't know if
that's something that you've you've done
before with this particular property
um
but i could look around um
i'm i could do tuesday or thursday next
week if either of those are any good
tuesday okay what time
[Music]
three o'clock works that's fine
okay cool i know where it is because i
got i've got the address if you could
just text over the exact address
um and then just confirmation and i'll
see you at 3 o'clock on tuesday
no i wouldn't be living there myself
that's why i said i've got a company but
um
yeah i mean
we can talk through that when i see you
as well i would work but uh we've got
we've got quite a few uh apartments that
our company rent so as far as as far as
as far as we're concerned 950 is fine so
we could just pay that we could fix um
you know fix the turn so uh yeah happy
days
isn't this illegal
and the answer to that is
no it is not illegal rent to rent is not
a new thing it's been around for years
it's something that's very very commonly
accepted in commercial property in
businesses all this is is it's a
business agreement on a residential
property so as long as you use the right
agreement if you use an ast contract and
then just sublet it then that is illegal
but if you use a correct contract and
that is a management agreement a
corporate let and tell the landlord what
you're doing it is perfectly legal now
if there is a mortgage on the property
and you're turning a buy to let into a
hmo will you need permission from the
lender now it might be that the lender
has restrictions on turning it into a
multi-let if there are restrictions from
the from the lender then you'll need to
ask the lender's permission this is just
general standard practice in property
investing if you're going to rent
something out you need permission to do
that and if you're going to rent out in
a peculiar way such a service
accommodation or buy the room on a
multi-little hmo of course you're going
to need to make sure that the lending on
the property is fit for purpose with
what you actually do with the property
the qualification of the house needs to
be that the house
can achieve a lot more rent than it is
currently doing so what kind of house
would that be well there can be
different types of examples one might be
it could be that the house is a big
house and it's being rented out and it
could be rented out into different
separate units so that could be a hmo
for example this is the most popular
type of rent to rent so you've got a
five bed house the landlord is renting
the whole thing out for 600 pounds a
month and it's near a city center and
you think hmm
he's renting it for 600 per month for
the whole house but if i came in and
just furnished the property made it a
bit prettier maybe paid for the all the
utility bills which might cost me a few
hundred pound a month i could then
re-rent out the rooms for 400 pound a
month which would be considerably more
profitable so it needs to be a house
where you can increase the rent another
example would be maybe if it's just a
little studio apartment in the city
center and it's renting out for 500
pound a month this little studio
apartment you could think hmm that
little studio apartment with a little
bit of creativity if i was to put a key
safe outside the apartment and was to
furnish it and include the bells i could
rent that out as a hotel like a hotel
without staff i could list this property
on airbnb and booking.com and instead of
getting maybe 500 pounds a month i could
get 500 pounds every few days in rent
from guests so you can massively raise
the rent on that you'll give the
landlord what he wants you'll rent the
property out for more and then you'll
keep the difference now i wouldn't
suggest doing a rent to rent unless the
difference is at least 500 pounds a
month so because it's not worth the
hassle if you're messing around secure
the deal with the landlord then you're
and you're going to make 200 a month i
don't think it's worth the hassle so
i'll be saying at least 500 pounds you
do not need a hmo license unless there
are five or more
tenants in the property now this does
vary slightly from council to council
but the standard rule of thumb is that
you'll only need a hmo license if the
property has five or more people now you
still will need fire doors and smoke
alarms to keep it safe but you will not
need a license nor will you need any
kind of rent to rent license in order to
carry out a rent to rent deal here's how
you have to analyze the rent to rent
deal so the first thing is you need to
be able to work out the return on
investment the return on investment of a
rent to rent deal now i
would never do a rent to rent deal
unless i was making a 100
return on investment on that deal now
when i'm investing in property because
i'm not just taking control of the
property i also own it and i'm
benefiting from the rent the cash flow
and the capital appreciation if i'm
getting 20 i'm really happy
if i'm if i'm taking control of
something i want 100 return on
investment what does that mean that
means what how much money are you
putting down to get the rent to rent
deal how much are you putting down in
terms of rent up front deposit to the
landlord
furnishings contracts
any fees associated with getting that
set up let's say that the
it's a 5 000
startup fee for the rent to rent and you
say
but then you're making a hundred pound a
month that's no good because a hundred
pound a month is twelve hundred pound a
year so your profit is twelve hundred
pounds but you put down five grand which
means it's going to take you years
like four years or more to get your
money back
no good you need to make your money back
in full
in the first year and that's like worst
case so if you're gonna put down five
grand
just to to get your rent to rent and
furnishings everything you need to make
at least five thousand pound profit in
your first year to make the deal even
worth looking at next what's your
monthly profit
what it how do you work out the return
investment so you need to look at if
you'll get paying the landlord a
thousand pound a month and you're
charging two thousand pound a month to
your tenants you might say oh i've got a
thousand pound a month profit no
you've got a thousand pound a month but
you've still got expenses so what are
the expenses with rent to rent there's
actually quite a lot of expenses you've
got to pay the landlord that's an
expense you've also got to pay if it's a
hmo or if it's serviced accommodation
which usually probably will be because
you've got to force the rent up you've
got to pay for the bills council tax gas
and electric you've got to pay for the
wi-fi so you've got all of the bills you
need to know how much those are going to
be now depending on the house if it's
just an apartment an airbnb apartment it
might only be 250 pounds a month maybe
if it's a 5-bed hmo it might be 500
pounds a month but you need to at least
have a ballpark figure and always air on
the conservative side when doing your
figures people with rent to rent what
they do is they manage it themselves
which does make it much more profitable
but then it's not completely passive but
you just you've got you've just got to
factor with what how you want to do it
do you want to manage it or do you want
to set or do you want to set up systems
where you don't manage it at all so once
you've worked out all the expenses and
then looked at what the total rent's
going to be
knock the expenses off of the rent and
you see the profit that's left take the
monthly profit times it by 12
and that will give you a figure which
will be your annual profit
then look at your expenses that you're
going to put down to get the rent to
rent and if you're not going to make
your money back within the first year
don't do the deal you don't need any
qualifications to do a rent to rent you
don't need a lot of money again i've got
students that have come into this
country with nothing and then doing rent
to rents within literally a few months
you do need to make sure you do properly
so you're going to need a a proper
agreement the type of agreement you're
going to need is you're going to need a
corporate let management agreement so
you can't do this with just normal asts
some people say you know oh is this
illegal it's illegal when you do it
wrong on the wrong contracts then it
will be classed as subletting when you
do rent to rent legally it it's
completely above board it's something
that even we've got solicitors who are
in our academy and they're doing this
strategy we've got estate agents doing
this strategy so hopefully that's kind
of clear that what rent to rent is if
you've got any questions about renter
rent whack them below in the comments
and maybe i'll do a more detailed video
answering your questions and please
don't forget to subscribe share and like
this video really appreciate the love
your success is my oxygen so i'm going
to keep doing these videos until you
keep becoming successful let me know
when that happens god bless
[Music]
you